since we're on social media websites
Tick Tock where do we rank that where do
we rank tick tock
see Tick Tock is hard because Don really
trying to get his social credit score
is hard I think because it's like I
think it there's a lot of like awesome
stuff that's come out of Tick Tock but
there's also a lot of [__] that's come
out of tick tock it's like really kind
of sitting on both ends of the space
yeah I I would say it's better than
twitch right now yeah I mean I I mean
it's like if twitch I don't really
compare them because they both do
different things
experiences
I I think it's just weird it's short
form content is kind of like it's it's
weird for me right just because not not
just because of the fact of short form
content but it's you know I've already
said that my life now in terms of
YouTube videos is run by an algorithm
and what it recommends to me but I at
least still feel like I have a choice
yeah yeah with the page yeah you can
pick I get presented with a page it's go
getting into short form content is weird
because it feels like here is just a
feed that is being directly fed into
your brain and you will consume the
content you will consume what ever we
present to you like it it did something
on another platform it did at the time
which was just immediately play and show
you something yeah and not allow you to
stop yeah and then figure out allow you
to choose yeah yeah and figure out based
on that watch time and attention and all
that stuff like oh this is a smart
system of how because if someone's
looking at what short form content to
watch they're not going to pick anything
sometimes it takes longer to pick the
[__] pigment to just watch something
yeah yeah it's a smart smart way about
it
um um yeah not really a huge fan yeah I
mean it's okay here do you think do you
think tiktok has uh completely changed a
whole generation of kids I feel like
with with Tick Tock and uh stuff like
you know Tick Tock Instagram Snapchat as
well which is like
I didn't even know Snapchat was still a
thing I've never felt more like a boomer
until someone talks about Snapchat and
how much [__] money Snapchat is
making I'm like holy [__] I am out of
touch right now you know I don't think
it's doing anything to our kids I think
it's the same it's probably what they
thought with us playing with like
[__] video games yes like yeah my
parents 100 felt the same thing
when you play with Pokemon I don't know
the attention span to read a book yeah
the screen you know I think I feel like
yeah he can't watch anything unless
Subway Surfers playing at the same time
what's going on that's a little weird um
the other kids these days I mean I've
seen some potato content where I'm like
yeah I'm glad the subway surfers
if it wasn't there I would skip that
[__] I mean it is certainly weird but I
think it's no different from what our
parents really felt with when we were
playing video games yeah when someone
was on Tumblr probably like oh my God
Tumblr yeah or before that newspapers
getting released yeah yeah like radio is
getting released I mean it's uh
I would like to get more into Tick Tock
but at the same time why not not get
more into Tick Tock but I would like to
be more aware about Tick Tock because
like obviously it's not I don't think
short form content is going to go
anywhere do I want short form content to
kind of take over no I'll I'll be honest
but I think it's kind of going to get to
the point where it is going to have a
much much bigger effect on just the kind
of media everyone consumes uh because I
remember when I started YouTube I'm
gonna go YouTube Boomer for a second
here
um I remember when I started YouTube uh
and YouTube was all about making videos
for desktops right when I started
YouTube in like 2007 there was like this
new feature that could tell you how many
people watched your YouTube video on
Mobile accounts and it was like two
percent yeah and I was like this is this
is such a non-factor why are we caring
about mobile watch time and now it's
just like the majority people majority
watch YouTube videos on a mobile device
and like I see the certain Trends where
as much as I complain about short form
content it is far too effective at
getting people's attention I I am like I
am one of I feel like I'm in the
minority where I have to like purposely
and consciously not watch too much short
form content because I can literally
feel my brain chemistry changing if I
watch it for more than 30 minutes I
reckon you know yeah yeah yeah it's it
yeah you you go into this trance and I'm
like this is too effective and just
because I'm aware of it I don't feel
like how big and how widely spread Tick
Tock is right now I don't feel like
people would be would keep this in this
in that conscious mind to be like no I'm
not gonna watch this much you know it's
uh it's something that's going to
continue to be more and more of a big
factor and I think you know just for
just to keep up with the current times I
should be more aware of it yeah yeah
what do you think about Instagram
because you're you're the instagramer
here am I I mean you're the closest
thing to your Instagram here you use
them I guess yeah Instagram for detail
for me
a detail yeah I hate it Instagram I
think I think Instagram is getting
better in a lot of ways because uh
recently especially they've really been
putting effort into like their reels
which is essentially just short form
yeah yeah right and like that has been
like really blowing up I know like I
know Aki started to do like a bunch of
reels on Instagram and they've done like
stupidly well uh even better than a tech
talk so it's like it is kind of
fascinating how that kind of content
also is working really well on Instagram
and I feel like at this point already
like every single social media like
thing maybe like other than Twitter is
like really leaning heavily into that
like short form video and like even you
know dedicating spots to their like UI
to be like here's where all the short
form content is because like on
Instagram there's just like a real
section now that you can just go to yeah
and you can just infinitely scroll short
form videos and memes and stuff like
that on Instagram and like I'm now when
I'm looking for memes I go on Instagram
reels like it is the I think it is the
best place to find memes now because
it's like I used to do that on Twitter
now Twitter has turned into a [__]
Cesspool of just like [__] I don't want
oh my God Twitter Twitter I think now is
Twitter's like an ET yeah Twitter's like
eat here yeah right like for me now it
used to be like C tier Beauty because at
least I I used to at least have a poster
too where I'd enjoy going on Twitter
um but the more I the more Twitter has
gone into like Elon musk's Pockets the
more I'm like this is going lower and
lower into the tier list the point where
I'm like maybe I should go on Instagram
I'm actually I'm actually nowadays I
found I'm using Instagram more than
Twitter yeah which is like never
happened in the the entire time I've had
both platforms like just because again
it's like you know I feel the Instagram
is great because it's like you know I
like taking photos and I like you know
and I have a lot of photos of me that
you know Aki or whoever takes so I'm
just like I need a place to put them up
yeah and you know it's also just uh I
think a nice I I feel like the community
on Instagram at least my community is a
lot more just chill on Instagram like I
can just I don't have to add any like
you know political or anything like
controversial to something or can be
misconstrued as that whereas on Twitter
I could say the most like innocent [__]
and people just misconstrued in a
completely different way and you know
that happens all the time whereas on
Instagram I feel it's a lot more chill
and again like the real systems are
really good uh you know like looking
through people's like stories and stuff
like that is like you can get that done
way faster on Instagram than like going
through each individual person's like
Twitter account to see like what they're
up to and stuff because you know God
knows you can't go on YouTube uh you
can't go on Twitter anymore to be like I
wonder what my friends are up to because
it never [__] appears on your feed I
think the biggest thing I don't know if
you've uh I don't know if you guys have
noted this as well
um aside from the arguments which have
always been there on Twitter it there
seems to be I don't I don't know what to
call it but there seems to be a culture
on Twitter of like the slam dunk you
know
yeah just just I I guess racial culture
or something like that where ever it
just seems like everyone is looking for
that next stupid tweet to try the ratio
yeah I'm like it was funny when this was
first a thing but when I see this now
and on my feed there's some like racial
attempts every like second or third
tweet literally every tweet I see you
open up the comments yeah and like I
guarantee within the first 10 replies
there will be someone trying to ratio
someone yeah and I'm just like why why
what are you trying to prove yeah what
are you trying to prove I'm like okay
the Fun's kind of worn off now this is
kind of getting tiring you know it's
it's kind of like oh it it kind of is
fatiguing in a way just to see this many
people trying to like slam dunk ratio
this stupid dumb person I'm just like
Mitch you know maybe just let stupid
people be sometimes and I may maybe just
is it so wrong just maybe if you stopped
giving those stupid people attention we
would see less of it on Twitter yeah
yeah but the complete it is happening
right now and now it's just everything